dear viola dear sandra thank you jane
for inspiring me to stand up for myself
and make sure that i'm heard you never
know
what the impact of your actions are
gonna be and then you read a letter like
this
as an athlete we are able to use our
platform to help people see what's going
on
[Music]
it's an honor to be asian you can have
profound ripple effects
there's a core narrative about all of us
she's too hard she's too old she's too
much of everything and in many instances
it's wrong
[Music]
there was a talent show and i think
instantly the bullying stopped
it was the beginning of understanding my
own power
i thought if malala could do so much at
a young age maybe i can too so many
people around the world are speaking out
dear ava i'd be willing to bet that you
didn't realize the hundreds of children
you'd be saving from incarceration
that makes me emotional
steal that i've been able to accomplish
things which many believe were
impossible with my condition i owe this
enlightened
mindset to euler
andre you saw the beauty in me at a time
where i couldn't see it in myself the
world is full of inspiration
i have never been angry the best revenge
is to promote education you continue to
inspire a generation of people
billy i hadn't heard your voice my life
would look completely different i
realized i am the change i'm looking for
i can't make my life longer but i can
make it deeper
[Music]
dear billy
dear malala
dear laird dear jane
dear viola dear sandra
dear andre
dear ava dear kareem
what is your voice what are you gonna do
with that small dash of time that you
had
[Music]
may we keep riding the big waves may we
continue in the fight together dear
melodrama
dear sandra
i'm gonna make the claim that you have
the best face in the world
sorry that's hilarious
you